and of course we have to begin once
again in Memphis there are new
developments following the death of
Tyree Nichols a vigil was held in his
honor last night near the intersection
where police officers beat him after a
traffic stop he died in a hospital just
days later now the city has disciplined
or fired 10 police and emergency workers
who were at the scene including the five
officers who were charged with murder
you've seen them on videotape Lee's
Preston is in Memphis with more on the
story Elise good morning to you
good morning to you Gail it is clear the
city is trying to heal from what has
been a traumatic past few days yesterday
protesters peacefully gathered once
again demanding more than just
individual accountability
demonstrators in Memphis continued to
call for police reform Monday as Memphis
Police denounced that two more officers
had been relieved of their duties
pending an investigation
an attorney for one of the officers
Preston Hemphill confirmed his client
wore the body camera seen in this
footage during the initial traffic stop
Hempel is captured pulling nickels from
his car at attempting to taser him
after Nichols ran away Hemphill could be
heard saying this oh stop his ass
hempel's attorney says his client was
not present at this second scene where
the beating took place he has not been
charged with a crime the Memphis fire
department also announced yesterday it
fired two EMTs and a lieutenant who
arrived on the scene after the beating
for allegedly not administering adequate
care for nearly seven minutes we we pray
for healing in this city Monday night
mourners gathered out a vigil for
Nichols at the same spot where he was
beaten the 29 year old was a father to a
four-year-old son what can you do when
you experience trauma or when you have
difficult emotions administrators at the
Balmoral Ridgeway Elementary School in
Memphis are trying to help students
process their community's grief they're
not sure what those feelings are so it's
important to put a name to it so that
they can understand what this is that
they're seeing and how it's making them
feel I want you all to take out a sheet
of paper and a pencil the school's
counselor titantia White had students
write about their dreams for a better
Memphis it's sad we can't trust cops
they're supposed to save us not hurt us
I think there should be less violence in
the city in Memphis one thing we need is
more positivity to hear some of the pain
that were in some of those letters that
tells you that we have work to do we
have healing to do throughout the city
as Memphis continues to mourn the Biden
and Minister Administration announce it
will send four officials to Tyree
Nichols funeral tomorrow meanwhile the
Shelby County district attorney says
more charges could be forthcoming in the
Future Tony
I know you'll keep following it at least
thank you very much